do you still get thanking cards from
Dwayne Johnson for the rundown because
that movie you know let's be honest that
was I yeah I was just talking to Dwayne
last week about we keep talking about
doing another one I've asked you at
least five times
so we Street here's the problem right we
started to do another one and we have a
script written but the script was
written in Alaska and the freeze frozen
really really cold weather sure I'd like
to remember the monkey scene and the run
down where the month used mount to space
we had a similar scene with walruses
things got a little sexual with uh let's
not like glean meddling with the back
and the walruses but I think how can you
beat monkeys for something to throw it
an opponent to throw it Dwayne that is
violent and tough and menacing and maybe
a little sexual we came up with lorises
and everything was going great until
like basically we realized that Dwayne
is an island boy and there's no way he
was going to go up to Alaska for 3-4
months up so we're rebooting right I
think we might see we might see another
one one day because there's a lot of
people like me who love the first one
there have been waiting to see we you
know to basically we would love to see
something else I mean that thing I know
do you actually what do you think the
percentage chance is that it actually
gets made is the 50/50 or is it actually
better than the villain I'd say right
now it's 50/50
sure do you already have an idea because
the last time I spoke to you you I think
you told me we wanted to do it Jonah
Hill oh yes yes Jonah Hill Duane
walruses in Alaska that that got some
traction and then everybody got busy we
we might revisit that but just in white
I'm not saying that why but I can
promise you won't be Alaska what I
understand